1 il s'agit de comprendre qu'il faut
arrêter d'empêcher les paysans du monde
de se nourrir eux mêmes alors toute
règle a ses exceptions il ya des pays
qui définitivement ne pourront pas se
nourrir regardez l'egypte par exemple 85
millions d'égyptiens l'égyptien désert
complet traversé par une seule rivière
alors ils sont bons l'agriculture sur la
vallée du nil mais ces quatre pour cent
des terres on peut pas nourrir 85mm
personne sur quatre pour cent des terres
donc l'egypte de toute façon on
n'arrivera pas se nourrir
donc les pays qui sont au nord de la
méditerranée face un peu de rab pour que
les pays qui sont au sud dans le mérite
méditerranée mange un peu ça me paraît
pas mal je sais pas comment ils vont
nous le payer mais je sais que j'y mange
pas nous allons le payer mais c'est
aussi une autre grande loi l'humanité
c'est que même le crève la faim peut se
payer une kalachnikov donc je pense que
c'est bien que les pays du nord de la
méditerranée face un peu de rab pour les
pays du sud mais l'idée de nourrir
l'humanité c'est de la folie les
africains doivent manger de la
nourriture africaine il faut donc
améliorer l'agriculture vivrière partout
dans le monde vous avez identifié coup
d'août comme menace mise à part le fait
que les gens n'ont pas le nombre de
calories suffisante journalières alors
déjà d une contre enquête là on vient de
parler des 800 millions de personnes qui
se couchent avec le mal au ventre quand
fin mais il ya beaucoup plus que ça et
un milliard de prêts de gens qui eux se
couchent le soir avait quelque chose
dans le ventre mais alors il ne manque
qu'une seule chose toute leur vie par
exemple que du riz ou que des maniocs
donc leur santé gravement détérioré
parce qu'il manque de vitamines de
produits etc on est déjà 2 milliards
alors six jours je faire voilà il ya
aussi un milliard si ce qu'ils mangent
trop donc beaucoup en france dont 700
millions d'obèses carrément c'est à dire
des gens dans la santé gravement
détérioré parce qu'ils mangent trop
alors on est 7 milliards 3 sur la
planète si j'ajoute les 800 millions de
gens qui ont faim le milliard de gens
qui mangent mal le milliard 6 de gens
qui mangent trop c'est pas ringard de
tout l'agriculture pour plus de la
moitié de la population de la planète
c'est un souci quotidien qui détruit
leur santé
et donc il n'y a pas plus moderne que
l'agriculture basque en particulier
finalement c'est quoi les vrais
problèmes de l'humanité alors je vous en
cite par exemple sur mangé tous ça c'est
pas mal mais qu'est-ce qui s'en occupe
c'est dépaysant si on mangeait bien pour
qu'on puisse vivre longtemps et mourir
en bonne santé ce serait pas mal mais
c'est qui c'est quand même les paysans
mais si on veut aussi boire de l'eau du
robinet et ben générale est plutôt
polluer un peu par l'industrie mais
beaucoup par l'agriculteur d'autres
c'est à eux de s'en occuper et si on
veut fixer du carbone de l'atmosphère
parce qu'on a réchauffé la planète il
faut qu' il faut un petit peu là la
refroidir ben c'est les paysans c'est
pas les plombiers et les marchands de
téléphones portables tiens plantons des
arbres que l'on fixe le carbone et puis
si on veut vivre dans une campagne
accueillante les premiers qu'ils soient
de la nature c'est les paysans vous en
connaissez beaucoup de professions qui
sont à la pointe des vrais défis du 21e
siècle donc le paysan il n'est pas un
gars il est post moderne c'est vraiment
l'homme qui assure la survie pure et
simple de l'humanité comment comment
vous trouvez les pouvoirs publics
comment vous trouvez le traitement des
pouvoirs publics envers les agriculteurs
en vente en mai en france et puis en
europe
le pouvoir politique française qui
traite bien ses agriculture ses
agriculteurs alors il faut se rendre
compte que on a eu faim pendant des
millénaires
c'est pas par hasard que dans notre
religion majoritaire ça fait 2000 en
compte des données nous aujourd'hui
notre pain quotidien alors pour les gens
qui sont élevées maintenant aux corn
flakes et au et au mcdo comprennent plus
ce que ça veut dire mais la fin c était
une caractéristique de toute l'histoire
de l'europe et de la france il y avait
des famines tout le temps enfin les
derniers tickets de rationnement france
1949 comme un faut se rendre compte
quatre ans après la guerre quant à paris
on voulait acheter du pain fallait avoir
des fronts ne vais pas inventer long
mais fallait avoir le petit ticket qui
vous donne la permission de rentrer à la
boulangerie pour fricoter avec la
boulangère bléssé moyens et donc au bout
d'un moment bah c'est pas mal que ce
soit les gens des villes qui commandent
légende et vous vous débrouillez comme
vous voulez les agriculteurs mais
maintenant on veut produire on veut du
pain dans les boulangeries on veut de la
crème dans les clubs rivaux de la viande
dans les boucheries qu'on peut des
fruits et légumes chez les marchands de
fruits et légumes eh bien on l'a fait
tout d'un coup on a dit on investit
vraiment dans l'agriculture entre
parenthèses ça a été un phénomène social
d'une violence inouïe jusqu'au moment où
commence la politique agricole commune
européenne il ya huit millions
d'agriculteurs en france maintenant il y
en a 500 milles les 8 millions
d'agriculteurs n'arrivait pas nourrir
complètement les français les 500 milles
les nourrices largement coûte shoot de
pesticides ni produits finis cité je
vois là on produit trois quatre cinq
fois plus dans le même champ maintenant
on produit 8 tonnes de blé 12 tonnes de
maïs à l'hectare jusqu'à 50 tonnes de
pommes de terre donc on n'a plus faim
pour combien de proue du rabbin cru
alors effectivement on a fait au plus
simple enfin ce qui apparaissait dans
les années 50 comme le plus simple c'est
à dire je vais mobiliser énormément de
ressources non renouvelables pour
produire beaucoup de nourriture et pas
forcément mieux on était moins exigeants
ce moment là on voulait surtout manger
donc ce qu on a enseigné dans les écoles
d'agriculture compris celles que j'ai
dirigé c'était assez simple c'est
produire plus et pas toujours mieux avec
plus
et puis bah ça a marché pendant 40 ou 50
ans je veux dire il faut se rendre
compte qu'en france on a les paysans ils
sont un peu ringard et comptant quintaux
et pantone on a rajouté un quintal de
plus à l'hectare tous les ans tous les
ans pendant 50 ans moyennant quoi dans
les années 50 un paysan était content
quand il faisait 30 quintaux trois
tonnes de blé l'hectare maintenant il
est pas content quand il fait moins de
80 quintaux 8 tonnes donc ça marchait
et notamment à coups de mécanique
le tracteur le labour
on recommence à zéro et puis à coude
chimie les engrais pour nourrir les
plantes
les les fongicides pour les soigner
quand elles sont malades les
insecticides pour éliminer les insectes
et les herbicides pour éliminer les cds
puis surtout il faut saluer le fil de
fer barbelé quand même une invention
géniale depuis quel fil de fer barbelé
les grosses bêtes se mettre plus dans ma
chance il faut carrément beau magescas
bon ben ça marchait alors maintenant le
problème c'est que
on arrive au bout
de la planète c'est moi quand j'ai été
diplômé de l'école des mines de paris en
72 personnes m'avaient expliqué que la
planète se réchauffe et personne m'avait
expliqué que les ressources étaient
limitées on me disait bon il ya deux
mille enfants si mais c'est pas grave tu
va voyager là vous y est c'est quand
même incroyable donc maintenant
heureusement enfin en france aux états
unis avec toi même pour ce sujet même
enfin on peut pas livrer un bac + 5 sens
qu'on l'expliqué la planète se réchauffe
et les ressources sont limitées donc
faut regarder et bien donc on y était
donc on ne peut pas juger des choix qui
ont été faits dans les années 50 et 60
avec la perspective de l'année 2017 est
ce qu'en fait la planète a changé et
maintenant il ya d'autres choses alors
la première chose c'est que cette
agriculture tout chimique tout pétrole
ça y est ces inconvénients rattrape les
avantages vous ouvre une parenthèse une
question de l'internet quel rôle jouent
les organisations que monsanto ou
bailleurs selon lui ce selon vous dans
ce problème d'épuisement des seuls deux
côtés
alors moi je suis pas un adepte et elle
est gentille à les méchins on n'est pas
dans un western on vous second gelé
videmment ben il ya une demande pour des
anglais pour des semences et semences
améliorées pour les pesticides moyer des
petites boîtes qui seront mangés
l'hérault ce qu'ils mangent et les roses
et puis maintenant se retrouver avec 4,4
pour le monde entier on était à 7 il ya
trois ans puis se sont tous bouffés les
uns les autres bayer a mangé monsanto
les deux autres américains ont fusionné
et puis il ya les chinois qui ont acheté
les suisses 2,6 gendt a alors évidemment
moi je trouve que c'est très dangereux
de confier l'avenir de l'alimentation du
monde à quatre monopole mondiaux en plus
pas publics mais en même temps il faut
pas confondre la cause et la conséquence
c'est qu'au démarrage
la volonté du peuple sait on veut manger
est la première solution c'est de dire
on va retourner on va mettre des
produits chimiques et bien les firmes
qui retournait qui vont des détracteurs
qui vendait les charrues celle qui
fournissait les semences qui fournissait
les anglais et que c'était ont prospéré
et c'est vrai que bell sont devenus
membres est donc relativement
incontrôlable mais même elle elle voit
bien que le monde est en train de
changer
regardez par exemple la france est un
très bon producteur de blé très grands
producteurs de blé on exporte et c'est
notamment dans la région parisienne
alors plus moderne que ça tu meurs je
veux dire nos rendements de blé sur les
meilleurs du monde entier
nous on trouve normal de faire huit
tonnes de blé l'hectare aux etats-unis
ces quatre tonnes en ukraine sur les
meilleures terres du monde ces trois
tonnes bon alors c'est super technologie
d alors on y va avec le tracteur ni avec
les engrais ni va avec les insecticides
et les herbicides les fongicides et tout
le toutim bon en 2016
printemps pourri ben on a eu la fin je
veux dire les terres qui étaient plane
complètement inondée ça pourrit pas de
blé
les terres qui est en pente au moins ça
drainer l'eau mais comme il est plein
nuage y avait moins de rayonnement et au
total la récolte de blé française - 30%
alors tu as l'air vachement moderne avec
tout son équipage mais quand il pleut tu
récoltes pas voilà en 2010 est là était
plus printemps plutôt sec mais canicule
à faut se rendre compte qu avant avant
de réussir pour le climatique les
canicules en france elle savait la
décence d'arriver quand le blé était
déjà récolté
maintenant il ya les premières canicule
arrive au mois de juin le blé lui peut
pas se pète à l'ombre et pas comme une
maison de retraite etc et le blé quand
il fait trop chaud au moment où ils
forment semblait mais les petites
faiblesses donc 2010 est pas terrible on
est les meilleurs du monde les plus de
technologie au monde et on entre en
train de voir que quand ces printemps
pourri en récoltent pas quand ces
printemps ton chant récolte pas alors
moi j'ai envie de dire quand est ce
qu'on récolte et puis tous ces produits
chimiques produisent leur anti c'est à
dire tous les insecticides qu'on a
inventé au bout d'un moment les insectes
ont vacciné contre l'insecticide sa
seleccion les insectes qui sont vaccinés
et pareil pour les mauvaises herbes et
donc maintenant les inconvénients
de cette agriculture tout tracteur tout
chimique arrive et institut lié si
toutes les boîtes de produits chimiques
se mangent les uns les autres c'est
qu'elle voit bien qu'il va falloir faire
un énorme effort de recherche pour tout
changer par exemple le chiffre essentiel
à mon avis du fait que bayer se soient
payés l'entreprise la plus impopulaire
au monde monsanto la seule entreprise
qui réussit ce tour de force de faire
une journée mondiale contre elle parce
que bon il ya d'autres entreprises comme
par la côte mais j'ai jamais vu de
journée mondiale contre le sieur ou
contre peugeot mais il y en a une contre
monsanto bon et de temps en temps les
gens disent mais pourquoi est-ce que
bayer va payer 60 millions de dollars
pour se payer d'entreprise 60 milliards
pour payer une entreprise aussi
impopulaire mais le vrai chiffre c'est
pas ça le vrai chiffre c'est que
bailleur monsanto annonce on va dépenser
deux milliards de dollars en recherche
tous les ans au mois deux milliards de
dollars je me suis demandé ce que
c'était chez libé tient on à très gros
organismes de recherche publics en
france l'inra tient des plus gros
organismes de recherche mondiale son
budget chez 800 millions autrement dit
bayer monsanto ils sont tellement
inquiet sur l'avenir de l'agriculture
qui vont embaucher trois fois plus de
chercheurs de l'inra
parce qu'il voit bien que tout va
changer avec le réchauffement de la
planète
avec l'épuisement des sols avec le
développement de résistances à ces
produits il va voir tout réinventer et
du coup on a fait une révolution
agricole complète au moins dans nos pays
est-ce qu en afrique qu'on l'a pas vu un
on l'a vu en asie en inde et en chine on
l'a vu en amérique latine dans la vie en
europe 1 l'a pas vue en europe la halle
à l'afrique les rendements restent
épouvantablement bah non mais cette
révolution
elle arrive au bout tout ce qu'elle peut
donner or il faut encore augmenter 70%
la production agricole mondiale donc ça
c'est un chiffre fondamentale du foot
vous l'expliquions alors pas en france
soyons clairs en france on mange déjà
trop et on fait plus d'enfants donc
l'idée de dire faut produire plus de
nourriture pour les france elle est
absurde pas les européens elle est
absurde
et en afrique la population va doubler
la population va doubler donc il faut
doubler la production agricole mais
actuellement en afrique à 40% à peu près
de la population qui mange pas à sa faim
donc en afrique faut tripler la
production agricole et encore je vais
vous dire faut tripler la production
agricole si tous les africains restent
végétarien s'ils se mettent tous à
manger bifteck là faudrait multiplier
par 5 en asie faut doubler
ils n'y arriveront pas non plus parce
que les asiatiques contrairement aux
africains face est très difficile de
faire des généralités comme ça ils sont
bons en agriculture mais il ya très peu
de terre et très peu d'eau donc il faut
se rendre compte que il ya un énorme
problème de quantité temps deux
continents du monde l'afrique et l'asie
heureusement il ya l'amérique qui du
nord au sud va pouvoir faire du rab de
façon permanente et qui va nourrir un
peu shanghai et new probablement on n'a
pas besoin de produire plus pour les
européens mais quand même c'est pas mal
quand fasse un peu de rap pour les
libyens les égyptiens dont il sait
jamais et puis surtout sur nos terres il
faut continuer à produire mais c'est pas
mal de produire un peu de médicaments un
peu de sacs plastiques pour pas de tirer
du pétrole un peu de deux d'isolants
pour un peu dhabi et c'est donc faut
quand même produire plus jeu mais il
faut en dire plus et mieux avec moins
qui est beaucoup plus amusant beaucoup
plus intéressant mais beaucoup plus
difficile que produire plus et moi mais
avec plus ce qu'on sait faire on viendra
la question sur comment les t'interesse
et agriculteurs plus tard les nouvelles
tendances et nouvelles tendances
alimentaires genre véganisme végétalisme
est ce que pour vous c'est un un
épiphénomène ou c'est vraiment une
solution durable alors levé gagner et
anne épiphénomène mail est révélateur
d'un phénomène fondamental
alors il faut se rendre compte que dans
toutes les cultures du monde toutes les
couleurs de peau toutes les religions
on rêve de manger ce que les riches
manger
et quand on devient riche petit riche et
bien on mange des produits animaux qui
est le symbole de la nourriture du riche
partout alors avec des croyances
différentes en inde on boit du lait mais
on mange pas de viande parce qu'on croit
l'incarnation donc traire la vache ça va
mais la manger c'est peut-être
grand-mère donc quand je veux pas la
manger et en chine celle inverse en
chine on mange tous cas n'est pas de
souffler table donc à aucun problème on
mange de la viande mais le lait c'est
pas leur truc bon heureusement puisque
nous c'est de la folie c'est la totale
et quand gilles un total en france on
sait indexé sur le millésime faut se
rendre compte que la consommation de
viande et de lait dans les années 20 20
kg 20 kg de viande d'un kilo de lait
dans les années 50 50 kilos dans les
années 80 81 kg et au tournant du siècle
100 kg génial alors du coup tout
l'élevage européen et notamment français
il s'est organisé par des abats on va
produire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
alors seuls les naïfs pense que les
coops pour longer indéfiniment
raisonnons par l'absurde d'économistes
on va bâtir et ben en 2100 200 kg de
viande pour tout le monde en 2000 200
300 kg de viande en 2004 104 kg d'or au
bout d'un moment ça s'arrête et la
réalité c'est que ça s'est arrêté en
l'an 2000 mais avant on le voit même
dans le vocabulaire parce que avant
l'ouvrier et gagner son pain à la sueur
de son front ensuite s'est mis à gagner
son bifteck ensuite il a mis du beurre
dans les épinards
et c'est vrai que le rêve de tout
ouvrier de manger comme le patron alors
maintenant les patrons des nouveaux la
google moi j'ai choisi sont tous
végétariens donc si tu veux manger comme
le patron mais on voit bien le produit
qui est abondant qui est facile à
acheter il devient banal
à partir du moment où il devient banal
tout arrive alors il ya des gens qui
sont au bout des lèvres mois terminés je
veux plus manger les aliments bon il ya
les gens qui sont sensibles à la
souffrance animale il ya des gens qui
veulent pas que les abattoirs etc il ya
des gens qui disent oui mais ça donne
l'artériosclérose
ça peut donner le cancer ça fait grossir
celle ci c'est cela c'est moins modernes
bon 200 kg aujourd'hui on en est à 85
alors d'un côté tout le monde sait même
puisque tout le système de production a
été fait pour produire plus
mais ceci dit il ya bien des viandes
regardez monsieur d'où par exemple
monsieur 12 spécialiste du poulet pas
cher alors lui son modèle économique il
est assez simple j'apporte du maïs du
brésil j'apporte du soja d'argentine
j'importe de subventions de bruxelles
plus que je suis tous les cas aucun goût
je laisse urgell je remplis un bateau et
je les vends arabe bon ben j'ai modèle
économique comme un autre
l'europe il ya sept ans a dit dans cinq
ans j'arrête les subventions alors je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans la tête
des éleveurs mais j'en dise non jamais
il avait fait quand même cinq ans
pendant cinq ans les brésiliens ils ont
réfléchi sont dit mais quand on y pense
attendait c'est mon maïs et mon soja
faire du pô les cas aucun goût c'est
vachement facile ils ont été voir
monsieur donilon tu peux pas nous
envoyer quelques techniciens on a envie
de faire les poulaillers et puis
monsieur d'où il est pas fou il a dit
bachir rives je vais me payer les
poulaillers au brésil
bombay à bout de cinq ans les
subventions sont terminés ben voilà tout
ça s'est cassé la figure mais attendez
on peut pas reprocher aux brésiliens te
dire c'est mon maïs et mon soja c'est à
moi de faire le poulet qu aucun goût
mais moi j'habite engin tout à côté
d'angers
il ya une petite ville charmante qui
s'appelle loué à louer tout le monde
seul ou du poulet de loué mais oui mais
en bresse aussi le poulet de bresse ça
marche très bien dans le béarn aussi
parce que le français qui est moche - de
poulet et des gens mangent moins mais je
voudrais qu'il est d'hugo recule un peu
d'énergie qu'ils soient balèze la
campagne qu'ils aient mangé un ver de
terre parce que ça se sent donc à poules
et poulets
et il va se passer dans la viande ce qui
s'est passé dans le vin ce que pareil
dans les années 50 quand on mangeait que
50 kg de viande est bien le litron ça y
allait vite rue d'antin combien et ben
c'était 140 litres de vin par tête de
pipe et par an bonne soirée curé
comprise et à ce moment là le litron
c'était 80 cents types de drôles et de
francs le litre
et bien tout d'un coup les français ont
dit quand même boire à ce point-là du
gros rouge qui tâche avec de l'eau
dedans et c'était assez bien mon chez
moi alors au début manifestation monstre
d'agriculteurs à carcassonne et narbonne
et maintenance et 40 kg 40 litres de vin
n'est pas su 240 à 40 au fait est ce qui
a encore des viticulteurs oui c'est
incroyable même à carcassonne même à
klaxons qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont des bains au lieu de te vendre le
vin par litre je vais te le vendre par
75 centilitres alors 80 centimes
franchement c'est nul non ça va être 5
euros minimum les 75 centilitres mais le
jour où tu reçois des amis tu passes
quand même à 8 euros ou 10 puis alors le
jour de fête tu passes à 15 eh ben c'est
à dire que il faut se rendre compte que
dans ce pays il ya plus de piquette y a
plus droit rouge qui tache et avec du
bon et du très bon vin eh bien il va se
passer pour la viande ce qui s'est passé
pour le vin c'est à dire que moi je
pense dans les années 2050 on ne mangera
plus que 50 kg de viande et 50 kg de
lait pour donner sens pour des raisons
économiques pour des raisons d'abord
culturel c'est que on en mange beaucoup
trop qu'est ce que c'est que cette folie
de dire je vais manger des lasagnes
cheval romain le soir alors que j'ai
mangé un bifteck émis dès maintenant va
pas manger 14 fois de la viande par
semaine est ce que vous savez pourquoi
on fait d'utiliser new cheval
attendait ça c'est autre chose à partir
du moment
où on veut manger une part de lasagnes
et un euro cinquante jeudi à temps il
faut pas prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles ça n'existe pas un plat de
viande un bon plat de viande 1 euro 50
et donc quelque part on se ferme les
yeux quand on achète un plat de viande
tout fait déjà cuit un euro cinquante on
achète du trader fou h et prend on
achète
la misère dans l'élevage et on achète
finalement un appel d'air pour qu'ils
aient un gars un peu plus malin que les
autres qui retire l'étiquette de boeuf
l'étiquette cheval en mettant mickey and
nicky de boeuf parce que évidemment
comme la roumanie et rentrer dans
l'europe la roumanie ce modernise elle
change ses chevaux pour des gens pour
des tracteurs il ya plein show sur le
marché et donc il ya des gens pour
truander il est sur le fond sur le fond
est-ce que tout va pouvoir se payer des
lasagnes à la ville et surtout dans ce
double rock
c'est à dire c'est un point de pouvoir
d'achat comme une chance de nous il n'y
a pas de raison de manger autant de
viande ya rien de mieux le soir qu'une
soupe de légumes ils soupe de légumes
c'est à la portée de tout le monde de
légumes de saison bien sûr un a il faut
bosser un peu vous faire les peluches
alors là de temps en temps me traite de
machiste mais attendait chez moi c'est
moi qui fais les peluches pour les
soupes 1 je veux dire les hommes on doit
le faire la peluche il n'y a aucune
raison de manger de la viande de
soissons 1 à manger à midi mia même
aucune raison de manger tous les jours
de la viande dans le temps les curés
nous disaient d'accord la viande mais
pas le vendredi par les vieilles de fait
pas le carême pas l'avant alors
maintenant c'est les écolos les
économistes pas de viande moulin du roy
pas de viande le vendredi partir du
lundi 20 portes moi je dis allez la
viande quatre fois par semaine c'est
bien du poisson une ou deux fois
végétarien une ou deux fois et puis
quand j'ai de la viande mais combien il
n'y a pas besoin d'un bit tech 250 g
alors je dis oui un jour de fête
d'accord mais moi c'est avec mon épouse
habitent est de 150 grammes pour 2,75 g
ça suffit autrement dit ce qu'on sera
évidemment faire dans la géant délais ce
qu'on a fait dans le vin le problème de
l'élevage c'est de dire comment je passe
d'être complètement organisée autour de
la quantité un truc organisée autour de
la qualité et comment je mets des chine
de qualité pour que celui qui achète son
bifteck de 70 grammes seulement quatre
fois par semaine dit oui d'accord je
peux bien le payer mais alors je veux
qu'il soit bon 1 alors bon le problème
c'est que la qualité il y en a plein
alors il peut être bio écolo locale je
me rends hommage à jouer m'enfin c'est
bien ça à votre avis est ce qu'il est
possible de nous tout le monde du moins
tous les humains avec du bio entre
guillemets alors saleh doit faire ma
culture voilà ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
bio
le bio
jusqu'à ses ultimes conséquences
c'est-à-dire 0 produits chimiques jamais
face 0 produits chimiques ça dépend
lesquels nous cuisinerons juste quand
même de cuivre et du souverain s'est pas
complètement naturel m'enfin bon zéro
produit chimique entre guillemets
interdit ça c'est réservé à une minorité
je veux dire c'est les gens qui aiment
se compliquer la vie y'a jamais 100%
d'une profession qui veut se compliquer
la vie c'est bien plus compliqué de dire
quoi qu'il arrive je mettrai jamais de
désherbants chimiques que de dire le
jour où j'ai loupé le truc bah tant pis
je mets une fois du désherbant mais une
fois tous les cinq ans donc ce n'est pas
du tout pareil combien de temps les
produits phytosanitaires raison de sols
alors ça dépend chaque fois des produits
phytosanitaires mais vous balance en
france on balance en france combien
combien de tonnes de pesticides sur le
territoire en est la meilleure
agriculteurs du monde donc mais on est
aussi l'agriculture la peluche tout est
à tout ça comme un tonneau bon je vais
pas vous donner des chiffres parce que
parker
énormément dushku et non mais on met
énormément en tournée c'est sid voilà
donc par exemple en ce moment ça tombait
septembre 2017 on nous parle de
l'insecticide le plus répandu dans le
monde qui est un herbicide s'appelle le
glyphosate plus connu sous son indice et
non commerciales qu'elle roundup bon
c'est vrai que c'est très simple de dire
je balance cet herbicide total c'est à
dire c'est un seul ticket tôt et puis
match pour planter bon alors il y en a
qui disent il est probablement
cancérigènes alors moi je suis pas
scientifique j'en sais rien voilà il ne
négligeons pas le fait que peut-être il
peut avoir des inconvénients sur la
santé mais surtout je dis c'est une
manière très primitive de voir les
choses que alors là prenant du recul
la biodiversité suis aussi les petites
bêtes et les types de plantes qu'on
n'aime pas la biodiversité c'est aussi
les moustiques par exemple on a
découvert il ya pas longtemps que les
poules ont des peaux et bien les
éleveurs de poules qui soit bio ou pas
et j'aime pas les poux et les paysans de
tout temps depuis de tout âge ils ont
été embêté parce qu'on appelé
improprement les mauvaises herbes voilà
maintenant des qui sommes nous pour
donner des qualités bon ou mauvais enfin
des plantes indésirables qui se font
leur place à la place de la plante qu'on
veut on appelle ça les adventices et
donc ils ont tous dit mais moi je veux
commandes et donc je veux pas que ces
adventices alors le premier truc a été
de dire on va faire flamber fait tout
flambé après la récolte ou encore mieux
ont fait flamber la forêt on cultive
pendant deux ans pour faire refluer la
forêt puis alors du coup les mauvaises
herbes mais elles n'ont pas le temps
c'est quand même très primitif alors
ensuite on a dit bon on va les enfouir
retourner quand on pense toute l'énergie
qu'on a dépensé depuis des millénaires
pour retourner mais si très primitif de
retourner parce que les adventices c'est
des plantes bien plus résistantes que
les plantes convainc et en particulier
elles peuvent durer 5 à 7 ans dans la
terre avant de crever
donc quand on retourne la terre tous les
ans à la première à laisser régler mais
la deuxième a dit ah bonjour les
adventices de il ya deux ans comment ça
va bon autrement dit quand on commence à
retourner faut retourner d'où le temps
est donc tout d'un coup il ya eu une
invention géniale j'arrête de brûler
finalement c'est pas grave si je
retourne pas je vais empoisonné
sélectivement ces plantes la
sambre sans empoisonner les autres mais
faut se rendre compte que d'aller dans
les années 50 c'est un mot dernier c'est
incroyable une personne se doutait que
ça les répandre le cancer le truc bon et
donc un prix nobel un fait l'inventeur
du ddt il est le prix nobel quand même
c'est probablement un des hommes qui a
sauvé le plus de vies dans le monde
maintenant on cancer le dtt c'est quand
même une super salle au briquet d'un
super des maladies mais dans le temps
qui reçut perles ou ton voilà qui reste
super longtemps alors faut se rendre
compte que la plupart des pesticides des
années 50 et 60 ça y est ils sont
interdépendants la trouver d'autres je
reviens sur ma question vous n'avez pas
une petite fourchette à nous communiquer
sur combien tonnes de pesticides ou
des dizaines de minutes transférer vous
savez par exemple année le roundup a
mauvaise presse mais il vous savez comme
une personne achète du roundup tous les
en france des millions
tous les banlieusards
je veux dire pour l'heure à l'est où il
ya des mauvaises herbes c'est fatiguant
de s'épancher europe je ne vis que
l'entraîneur lyonnais avec des derbies
en amérique de cette émission sur ma
fille et je suis en morose et que je
devais le petit aussi donc et quand vous
voyez là dedans quand vous plaît si
j'ose dire quand vous voyez par exemple
la concentration de ces produits qu'on
balance
augmenté pour dire on balance - de
tonnes si l'accès des produits qui sont
plus concentrés talea tarder soyons
clairs on est complètement shooté à ça
je voulais qu'il faut arrêter shootée à
quel degré est ce que c'est on lé plus
chaud thé au monde voilà c'est
irréversible un nom évidemment
supérieure alors tiens par exemple
on y va on est ok alors je vais pas
brûler
je vais arrêter de retourner parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que labourage et pâturage
étaient les deux mamelles de la france
et que le labour finalement c'est une
histoire de fou faut arrêter de labour
et ben voilà à terme pour arrêter de
labourer faut cultiver les champs 365
jours par an faut arrêter d'embêter les
vers de terre faut arrêter d'embêter les
bactéries faut arrêter d'embêter les
champignons mais du coup bah quand je
plante mon blé ou mon colza j'ai aussi
des mauvaises herbes alors du coup si on
veut plus les empoisonner avec le
désherbant sélectif qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
c'est là qu'il faut se rendre compte de
l'ampleur de notre ignorance en fait on
ne connaît strictement rien nature alors
je vous donne un chiffre par exemple
sous un mètre carré de terre il ya 260
millions d'êtres vivants je dis bien de
160 millions ça explique pourquoi on dit
on connaît très peu la biodiversité ans
quand on connaît que 10% des êtres
vivants alors je vous rassure on connaît
tous les rhinocéros on connaît toutes
les girafes moi je vous parle côté
petites bestioles bon alors quand la
main de l'homme ne met pas le pied comme
on disait
un peu facile bon c'est à dire les 2
systèmes de production de matières
végétales les plus élaborés au monde il
n'y a jamais eu de labour jamais
d'engrais c'est la forêt primitive le
mucus et la prairie eybens et ses 260
millions de bestioles qui cèdent entre
elles et puis c'est de la biodiversité
c'est 70 80 plantes différentes dans le
même champ
oui mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est du blé
ou du maïs ce principalement ben on peut
avoir des plantes de compagnie voilà
c'est à dire que en même temps qu'on
s'aime par exemple comme ça on sème une
plante
qui nous intéresse pas pour manger mais
qui nous intéresse pour ce qu'elle va
faire et par exemple chez une plante
avec des des feuilles larges et qui plan
qui poussent vite et donc elle pousse
elle s'étend elle étouffe les autres
mauvaises herbes ya plus qu elle et le
colza
et puis ben on il ya une deuxième
qualités qu'on lui demande c'est de
geler l'hiver d'être comme on dit j'ai
livre donc à l'automne elle empêche les
mauvaises herbes de pousser
l'hiver elle gèle mais elle reste là or
c'est du carbone de l'azoté de
l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène autrement
dit elle sert d'herbicides et ensuite
elle sert d'engrais et puis au printemps
bella le colza à l'huile et vigoureux
c'est lui qui pousse qui empêche le
reste de pousser et donc la nouvelle
agriculture c au lieu de détruire la
nature par des pour les chimiques
je comprends quelles alliances je peux
faire avec tel insectes tel oiseau ou
telle plante d'accompagnement
ddd
des animaux auxiliaires de culture et
notamment les petites bêtes qui mangent
les petites bêtes qui mange mes plantes
me retrouve dans bien nourri le plant de
couverture qui empêche les mauvaises
herbes on a redécouvert la roue c'est
sympa ce qui les inquiète faisait
exactement une jouer ma faim moi je vous
parle d'une agriculture à 8 tonnes de
blé ha ha oui il s'agit de faire ça en
faisant huit tonnes de blé ktar parce
qu'on ne peut pas revenir 4 tonnes parce
qu'on à 7 milliards 300 millions de gens
à nourrir on va bientôt en avoir 9
milliards et demi il faut absolument
continuer à produire massivement de la
nourriture alors si on ira si on en rit
jean le monde oui si on ne va pas dans
les secours n'arrivent passer les
familles et donc vous me parliez de la
blu la bio
pour le moment alors je suis désolé je
suis sûr qu'on a plein d'amis bio qui me
regardent on est nuls en bio allez vous
faire une petite pique c'est un peu de
votre foot l'inra ils ont grand ensemble
d'euros cher 6100 sont chercheurs côté
pas tout il 50 petits bouts et donc on a
mis toutes nos forces dans l'agriculture
chimique heureusement il y avait un
barbu chevelu chemise à fleurs font du
massif central qui continuaient bon
heureusement qui titre timaeus ami qui
était traité de ringard et cetera mais
heureusement qu'il était là mais sur le
fond dit l'agriculture chimique les
découvertes sont derrière nous
l'agriculture bio toutes les découvertes
sont encore à faire puisqu'on était très
peu à faire donc il va y avoir autant de
découvertes dans les 30 ans qui viennent
dans l'agro écologie intensive qu'il ya
eu dans les cinquante ans passés sur la
chimie mais il y aura encore de la
chimie d'ailleurs qu'est ce que est ce
qu'on voit maintenant dans les écoles
des des barbus newedge est echl ou des
dreadlocks enseigne oui c'est à dire ça
commence à en découvre une chose c'est
que attendait le sol
le seul fait est devenu un support qu'on
remue est avec des charrettes plus en
plus profonde pour tous neutralisés et
on mettait des poudre verte violette
jaune à pois bleus sous du tout d'un
coup on dit mais attendez ce que
d'autres l'avionique c'est dans le sol
et la différence c'est la conjugaison
entre la bio et le numérique tout d'un
coup
on a l'espérance de faire connaissance
avec les gêne vraiment est vraiment avec
les 260 millions d'êtres vivants alors
qu'on les connaissait pas et on va
pouvoir faire une agriculture de super
précision parce que l'idée du pesticide
c'est à dire on connaît pas tous ces
trucs là donc je préférais toutes
éliminées pour recommencer à zéro
la nouvelle chimie c'est la chimie bio
respirez sais comment je peux faire pour
aider les bactéries qui fixe le
les éléments nutritifs à faire leur
boulot donc ça va être une chimie pour
aider
je simplifie les bestioles à faire leur
travail de bestioles face elle que je
veux plutôt que de disparaître et ça
c'est possible parce que on commence à
comprendre là fini mon petit con à des
sons maintenant et c'est qu'on va donc
pouvoir travailler un champ au mètre
carré et à terme à la plante et non pas
à l'hectare alors je vous pose je
voulais un
un cas concret vous valez dans la bouche
d'accord ensemble sur un champ de blé
qui a bien subi pendant cinquante ans le
modèle productiviste de la fin des
trente glorieuses
combien de temps il faut à ce chant pour
un revenir dans un état de santé normal
à les 5 à 7 en cinq sets on savait par
exemple l'europe a dit le gars qui sue
la fif
le paysan qui se convertit en
se disant pendant trois ans haulchin
mentionne pas ce que l'état l'état
français à un tournant
il arrête la subvention définitive mais
pas la subvention des trois premières
années ce que dans les trois premières
années c'est vrai la productivité
diminue mais je peux pas vendre ma
récolte plus cher comme des biopuces
qu'elle est réputée encore pas bio
pendant trois ans
moi ça si ce que tu me reste à partir du
moment où la bio devait un secteur
économique
de plein exercice je suis pas sûr que
pendant un siècle il faille continuer à
subventionner les prix de la bio parce
que si plein de gens mangent de la bio
mais ils ont qu'à cela payer si j'ose
dire et ils ont qu'a dressé les grandes
surfaces qui en profite au passage pour
doubler leurs marges pour gérer ça vous
coûte tout de bioux bas tout le monde
sait que ça vaut deux fois plus cher
grosso modo voilà mais c'est normal ça
vaille plus cher quand vous voyez qu'on
moment tout est petit c'est des petites
exploitations des petits récoltants des
petits commerçants etc etc au furet the
rule à biot est pour le moment la vie
augmente de 15% par an donc ça va le
faire notre problème en ce moment c'est
de trouver suffisamment de paysans pour
se convertir au bio parce que
l'appétence pour la bio en france va
plus vite que l'appétence pour le
produire donc du coup on achète du bio
ailleurs eia bio bio est ce que le bio
c'est toujours le plus contrôlé mais le
bio en colombie est quand même moins
contrôlés que le bon que le feu en
ardèche vous dans l'est de la colombie
qu'est ce que vous pensez des influences
du c'est un sur les solutions discutées
alors moi je pense que quoi qu'il arrive
la planète aura le dernier mot dans mes
coups sont nous avec we know mais même
avec nous je veux dire la réalité c'est
que ambrose 30% de moi était pluvieux et
10 à 15 % - était chaud et donc
cette espèce de délire technologique en
dix ans l'homme est plus fort que le
climat vous n'avez qu'à acheter des
semences et des pesticides et ben même
monsanto s'aperçoit que il va falloir
réinventer autre chose et que l'avenir
va être différent alors ça va aller plus
ou moins vite suivant qui a plus ou
moins de 7 à plus ou moins de résistance
plus ou moins de soucis plus ou moins de
cela est que le ministre de de
l'ecologie est plus fort que le musée de
l'agriculture ou l'inversé mais
la planète aura le dernier mot la
planèze puis rue dire elle s'en fout du
cours des tomates bio elle dit moi je me
réchauffe et les ressources s'épuisent
donc c'est comme vous voulez à la fin
j'aurais le dernier mot bon on va
essayer de raisonner comme un politique
d'accords notre politique qui veut que
le pouvoir d'achat s'effondre dans les
pays occidentaux que la crise est en
train vraiment d'arriver parce que vous
vois ma non mais comme vous dites dans
vos conférences quand les bobos
commencent à planter des pommes de terre
sur balcon c'est que la crise est
réellement la
halqa en france un chiche en train
d'ériger je n'ai pas vu mais sûrement
les banlieusards retirer leurs rosiers
pour mettre des patates heureusement les
bons clients laver en grèce les on a vu
la brillance égal on la joue comme ça
peut arriver que l'ajout portugal et on
a vu même même en grèce on a vu les gens
couper des arbres pour se chauffer des
arbres de ville donc ça paris d'accord
en france ça va arriver vous inquiétez
pas
quand on raisonne en tant que politique
on se dit que l'inertie du passage à une
alimentation raisonnée et heureuse cette
inertie va être néfastes pour la
stabilité de notre pays vous qu'est ce
que vous pouvez dire en tant qu ancien
directeur d'une école d'agronomie qu'est
ce que vous pouvez dire un politique
pour le rassurer sur cette inertie qui
risque de créer un trou d'air dans sa
chaîne d'approvisionnement
en gros
quand il n'ya plus de foin dans les
râteliers les chevaux se bat
alors deux choses
une observation sur les agriculteurs et
nos observations sur les consommateurs
une observation sur les grilles
agriculteurs j'ai passé 10 ans à diriger
une école d'agriculture angers au début
des années 2000 les fils de producteur
de cochon bretagne arrive est bien
dégagée sur les oreilles et quand je
disais c'est bien de manger des côtes de
porc mais ce serait bien de boire de
l'eau du robinet leurs réponses
stupéfiante était commun du pays
c'est pas possible de dire ça l'eau
c'est un bien collectif
tu peux pas dire combien tu payes pour
avoir le droit de boire de l'eau c'est à
toi et donc moi je disais bon tu vas
continuer à faire du cochon mais pas
comme des cochons voilà tu vas continuer
à faire du blé mais pas comme des
cochons donc je veux dire
l'environnement dans une école
d'agriculture ce n'est pas une matière
c'est une dimension totale
du métier on continue à se faire à
manger mais on en fait en respectant
mieux la planète alors maintenant de
l'autre côté
dans les années 60 quand on recevait son
salaire en france 30% du salaire c'était
pour manger et 14% pour se loger
quelqu'un aujourd'hui 16% pour se loger
quelques soucis n'ont en moyenne moyenne
14% pour manger alors évidemment quand
un ouvrier c'est plus que 14% et quand
on est trans et -2 14% même si on
dépense plus pour manger enfin on est
passé de 38 à 14 ça peut être pire aux
etats unis c'est 7% enfin moi la
gastronomie et la santé en amérique elle
me fait pas envie hein en général
d'ailleurs - on dépense pour manger plus
on dépense pour la médecine il doit y
avoir un petit rapport bon il ya
d'autres pays où c'est beaucoup plus bon
moi je dis 14 c'est bien voilà moi je
serais pas content dépensé 15 ou 16 %
pour manger
notre problème maintenant c'est dire
faut-il vraiment changé le téléphone
portable tous les six mois moi je dis il
est urgent de réagir de dire attendez
bien manger sa santé personnelle c'est
fondamental il est temps de se dire
dépenses en un peu plus de temps et
dépenses ont un peu plus d'argent pour
cette activité fondamentale mais c'est à
peine un peu plus quand je dis le soir
soupe de légumes c'est pas plus cher que
le lait zain et c'est bien meilleur pour
la santé à condition que ce soit des
légumes de proximité si possible un
bureau je suis relativement un kit
concernant le pourcentage de la
population en souffrance économique
pouvant s'acheter une alimentation qui
leur permettent d'avoir au minimum 1200
calories par jour
je pense que le prix de laquelle ils
vont augmenter et que l'inertie
sociétale de nos sociétés occidentales
va créer un trou d chez ces gens là
qu'est ce que de les énerver un petit
peu alors évidemment évidemment d'un
côté oui d'un autre côté je veux dire
bien manger c'est beaucoup plus un
phénomène culturel cas phénomène
économique
encore une fois on ne mange absolument
pas assez de légumes le légume il est
pas cher dans notre pays enfin le légume
de saison bien sûr un jeu d'ailleurs une
soupe de carottes poireaux et n'avait
l'hiver tout le monde post le pmm quand
on est au smic même quand on est au rmi
est donc le problème c'est aussi un
choix est ce que je veux une grande télé
ou une petite télé est ce que je veux
manger des la zenn le soir ou de la
soupe de légumes et c'est quand même
d'abord culturel et moi je dis oui on
peut dire il ya des gens qui sont plus
riches que d'autres mais le phénomène
culturel est fondamentale en france on
n'est pas un pays de la fin
tout le monde peut manger un minimum ce
que la fin je vais vous dire les
statistiques les 800 millions là c'est
ya un enfant qui meurt de faim toutes
les 10 secondes sur la planète toutes
les 10 secondes en france n'a pas je dis
pas qu a pas de misère en france je ne
dis pas qu'il ya pas de mal bouffe en
france mais fort heureusement chez nous
on a résolu se promène il n'y a pas
d'enfants qui meurent de faim toutes les
dix secondes qu'est ce que vous pensez
donc on peut se nourrir qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la junk food est ce que
c'est une nourriture qui a le
l'équivalent qu'on peut concevoir comme
drogue c'est à dire qu'est ce que les
gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup de pognon
s'achète de la bouffe qui leur actif des
zones dans leur cerveau on va dire comme
le sucre s'attendait c'est la coquille
du partant des shoots et au sucre et
quand on est chouchouté la matière
grasse c'est une forme de choc c'est
tout à fait une forte histoire que les
als que se forme de shoot je suis les
classes pauvres c'est une façon un petit
peu de prendre des antidépresseurs
oui non mais c'est d'abord culturel de
manger je veux dire heureusement chez
nous on boit quand même beaucoup moins
de boissons sucrées et c'était un beau
coin de coca etc c'est la coca cola inc
elle fait un tableau d'honneur de ses
meilleurs clients dans le monde son
meilleur client c'est le mexicain cemex
qui en sont à 280 km par tête de pipe et
et par an bon nous on n'est qu'à 60 donc
justement
les 60 là c'est plus les chômeurs les
classes populaires etc qui se shoote au
coca voilà c'est une forme de drogue est
ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'on veut
pouvant s'ouvrir ce jour là
mais écoutez l'eau c'est toujours moins
cher que le coca et
manger ça commence à l'école
je veux dire ça c'est quand un truc
énorme les distributeurs non les
distributeurs et puis la cantine alors
moi j'ai eu quatre enfants j'ai toujours
été à tous les conseils d'administration
de l'école collège lycée c'est le parent
d'élève adore parler de la bouffe
le prof à tort que les parents d'élèves
parle de la bouffe pendant ce temps là
il parle pas d'autre chose donc on parle
beaucoup des menus de la cantine et le
parent d'élève qu'est ce qui dit je
voudrais que le ticket de cantine soit
moins cher et ça au coach nerfs qui
lâchent pas démocratique il faut que le
peuple puisse envoyer ses enfants à la
cantine bon ok moyennant quoi c'est
tellement pas cher que 70 % de la viande
qui est servi dans nos cantines est
importé
et moi je dis
quand est ce que les parents d'élèves
vont dire moi je voudrais quand dans ma
cantine on servent de la nourriture dans
mon département puisque pour moi le
début des jeux dirait du lien social
c'est de manger de la nourriture qui est
produite à moins de 100 km alors je dis
pas pour les bananes bon ok enfin bon le
reste je veux dire quand il ya du
poulain la cantine moi je faisais du
coup les français je veux pas des
poulets
brésilien souverainisme il vanté non
mais dans les cantines et c'est pareil
pour les cantines et d'aider des
entreprises
la cantine ça devrait être le premier
lieu de la citoyenneté parce que bien
manger c'est pas seulement les calories
c'est pas seulement nombre de sucre de
trucs de machin c'est bien manger pour
faire société c'est quelle société je
crée en mangeant et c'est vrai qu'on se
dit les multinationales la publicité sur
méchant méchant mission au quai à la fin
des fins qu'est-ce qui fait les menus
qu'est-ce qui fait les courses qu'est-ce
qui décident de ce qu'on mange ce soir
c'est bien moi le portefeuille alors je
suis influencé et cetera par toute la
pub en déneigement bien de boire du coca
la compagnie d'un bond girl bien
graisseux ok mais la clé c'est d'abord
l'éducation et
c'est dans les changements
on a l'impression que c'est très lent
parce que la majorité du changement ça
se passe dans la tête tant que les
choses changent dans la tête en voit
rien et tout le monde est désespérée et
par exemple il ya quarante ans la
première fois que j'étais en allemagne
j'ai vu qu'ils triaient leurs poubelles
jeudi me sens jamais les français pour
en faire sa ba mais surtout si au fait
qu'est ce qui a fait le tri des
poubelles les instituteurs
les instituteurs ont dressé les enfants
des écoles contre leurs parents et les
gamins revenait à la maison du repas pas
quand même tu pour tree un peu et le
ba-ba honteux a commencé à trier bon
alors maintenant c'est pareil le jour
ils ont dit on ne fumera plus dans aucun
bistrots de france moi je dis jamais en
france en deux semaines c'était fait il
n'y a pas eu une seule manif de
bistrotiers disant j'ai juste qu'on fume
chez nous est ce que il en avait plus de
clients moi j'allais plus jamais dans
les bistrots s'appuient les fumées
depuis que je dis pas que je suis devenu
un pilier de bistrot mais je rentre dans
les bistrots depuis quand y fume plus
huppés bas les fumeurs ils sont dehors
ils consomment aussi bon alors
maintenant le fait que la planète se
réchauffe ça rentre dans toutes les
têtes sauf telle celle de trump le fait
que les ressources sont limitées ça rame
dans toutes les têtes et pourquoi on est
mûr pour changer pour changer ça
commence à table d'accord le goût c'est
pourquoi le trump sont pas dans sa tête
je ne suis pas dans la tête d'autres
hommes j'ai l'impression qu'un institut
le pouvoir d'achat et les droits
américains souhaitant négociable
oui mais vous savez quand on apprend qu
aux états unis du temps d'obama
ils ont voulu faire voter une loi car
afd obligatoire dans les cantines on
apprend avec stupéfaction qu'ils ont
demandé trois ans de délai pour mettre
cette mesure en place et donc quelque
part le lobby de la coca elle était pas
mal ils ont eu besoin de trois ans pour
acheter des carafes d'eau pour mettre
des carafes d'eau dans les cantines
scolaires donc en fait tout ça c'est
quand même beaucoup d'intérêt à qui les
loubinoux puisse
mais vous savez en europe dans combien
de pays on peut avoir une carte gratuite
au restaurant j'arrive de belgique en
allemagne faut acheter son nom c'est
incroyable fabre attendez le plus truc
démocratique c'est d'arriver au
restaurant donner moins de 40 ans j'ai
alors qu'ils essayent de dire vous la
voulez gazeuse cher mais mais le droit à
la carafe d'eau c'est un droit universel
et c'est d'abord un droit des pauvres
c'est un bon qu'on y donc tout ça c'est
quand même très fortement culturelle
s'est pas uniquement une affaire de
pouvoir d'achat le gâchis alors le
gâchis ça bon ben c'est tout un système
alors j'ai très difficile d'évaluer ce
qu'on gâche évidemment bus qu'on gâche
enfin grosso modo ils disent le tiers de
la récolte mondiale et jetés alors le
tiers de la récolte mondiale c'est très
différent suivant qu'on avait dans le
sud et le nord un dans le sud vers les
partager on dit je récolte et puis allez
ça je le donne pour les rares pour les
moisissures pour les oiseaux pour les
voleurs pour levante et moi je regarde
ça bah c'est pas beaucoup mais pourquoi
tu crois que tu as faim attendez ça fait
60 ans qu'on dit qu'on aide les pays
africains
bon vous comme ici lors en exportant de
la guerre ou sans l'aide non mais
soi-disant où sont les silos en afrique
où sont les tanks à lait réfrigérée
solaire c'est ça qui est pas mais c'est
quand même incroyable voilà des gens qui
produisent qui arrivent pas garder et
donc qu'ils ont faim alors nous ça va on
a nos silos nous engage sophistiqué un
rajoute d'abord du salaire l'échelle
sociale de l'emballage a vendu avant de
jeter bon alors faut se rendre compte de
chiffres de base
un humain s'introduit une tonne par an
dans sa bouche voilà 600 kg de liquide
400 kg de soliste un peu plus d'un kilo
par jour à ses ouailles canton d une
tonne ça fait réfléchir bien
alors quand on évalue en disant on jette
le tiers pour produire les 400 kilos que
j'ai mis dans ma bouche il a fallu
produire 600 et jeté deux sens tout le
monde se doute qu'en france on jette un
peu plus que la moyenne alors moins que
les américains mais bon moi j'estime 240
autrement dit le français il se met 400
kg
de solides dans la bouche et l'ange est
de 140 chaque française des gets 240
kilos de nourriture alors c'est vrai que
la première fois qu'on dit c'est à dire
pas moi pas si tout le monde
alors il faut analyser le truc s'est
divisé en trois
alors le premier temps il rentre dans
aucune statistique c'est le truc est pas
sorti du shop a sorti de la mer regardez
par exemple je sonne des carottes la
carotte voyons petit soldat fait son
trou y en a une qui trouve un caillou up
tordu à moi je vous pose des questions
vous envoyez des carottes tordu dans le
rayon légumes de votre supermarché bien
sûr que non la carotte tordu elle sort
pas du champ elle rentre même pas dans
les statistiques parce que je sais pas
pourquoi il ya un espèce de consensus la
carotte ça doit de droite les carottes
tordu ça existe pas jeter le pire mais
c'est pareil les cerises qui ont été
attaquées par l'api les melons que mt
etc on n'imagine pas tout ce qu'on jette
le pire c'est la pêche la pêche
maintenant c'est fou hein je rappe
jusqu'au fond je remonte tout absolument
tout et je fais le tri jeudi ben ça
c'est trop gros ça c'est trop petit sur
quotas ça je sais même pas comment ça
s'appelle ça le cours vient de tourner
en balance 30 à 50% de qu'on remonte
tout ça c'est pas dans les statistiques
c'est même pas rentrer au port moi
j'estime 80 kilos par tête de pipe
sur le mans b au chef du rayon légumes
de son supermarché de nous faire un
petit rayon de légumes moche en dire
mais pour la soupe et à il mieux que
l'art et légumes moi je te ligue moi je
suis qu'à lutter pour la survie il a
plus de go dans la soupe c'est vachement
bon la carotte tordu bombe a fait moi oh
moi je suis très et aux pistes
alors ensuite et un record 80 kg dans
toute la chaîne entre l'industrie le
transport et la commercialisation
mine de rien c'est pas rien et puis
encore deux fois 40 kg 40 kg chez nous
40 kg la cantine mais à la cantine vous
avez vu tout ce qu'on jette qu'est ce
que c'est que cette folie de dire ça
pourrait être du poison peut jamais à
servir les restes et c'est avec ses
tables je vous dis je suis dit l'un
d'entre eux mieux faire un
on ne peut pas baisser
totalement le gâchis moi je disais à mes
étudiants j'espère que quand vous aurez
mis mon âge au lieu de jeter le tiers de
la récolte on jettera que 25% de la
récolte vous savez on estime qu'on jette
un milliard trois cents millions de
tonnes de nourriture sur lieu de jeter
le tiers de la récolte on jette le cas
on récupère 300 millions de tonnes il ya
800 millions de crève la faim ces 300
millions de tonnes ils peuvent peut-être
servir à quelque chose donc j'en arrive
j'en profite pour prendre la parole pour
vous avez la bouche pleine
vous avez écrit un bouquin mangé tous eh
bien on en parlera après je vous
passerez vos bouquins pour qu'on puisse
les présenter la question je me pose
c'est si tout le monde mange
correctement y compris les huit cent
mille club nadal comment ça se passe sur
l'épuisement des ressources est ce que
votre modèle d'agriculture permet de
faire une boucle totale c'est-à-dire
réinjecter stabiliser le carbone
redonner un enjeu aux gens et ainsi de
suite est ce que ce cycle est tout à
fait vertu est ce que c'est comme ils
aiment l'appeler à dire c'est
l'agriculture heureuse
alors salaires faux de dire oui mais je
le dis tu es attendait ya aucun problème
pour produire assez de nourriture pour
10 ou 12 milliards de personnes
absolument aucun problème est justement
comme vous dites on peut transformer un
cercle vicieux avec de plus en plus de
chimie de plus en plus de tracteurs de
plus en plus de pétrole est de moins en
moins de de fertilité en un cercle au
contraire verture si on couvre le seul
en permanence
corot mais des arbres partout pour aller
chercher les ressources plus profond et
c'est comme et des mélanges de plantes
qui céda à pousser non seulement on
utilisera beaucoup moins de produits
chimiques mais c'est magique on va
capter du carbone dans l'atmosphère
et on va refroidir le plus qui en a bien
besoin deuxièmement va augmenter la
fertilité des sols et troisièmement va
se faire à manger donc on peut à la fois
se faire à manger augmenter la fertilité
des sols et refroidir la planète mais
c'est un choix qui nécessite un
changement complet de deux rapports à
l'agriculteur ce basculement des
consciences parce que maintenant 20
admettons qu'on donne à manger à 12
millions de personnes
ils vont vouloir peut-être acheter des
magnétoscopes des télés des dvd des
iphones rouler avec 4 bagnols
alors déjà parce que ce basculement des
consciences doit aussi s'effectuer par
cette filière de l'agriculture diamant
mais déjà dans l'agriculture il ya cette
affaire de transition alimentaire
j'ai un petit salaire je commence par
acheter un bifteck et puis de la grèce
bien graisseuse de l'huile bien huileuse
du sucre bien sucré jeu devient obèse
etc et puis à la fin on libère tout ça
est ridicule et on finit par les mines
est au contraire anorexique qui se
dorait d'une feuille de salade qui va
faire son jogging mais il faut accélérer
sa est donc dans tous les pays qui ont
commencé plus tôt leurs traditions
alimentaires et qui se bâfre et dans le
problème principal est l'obésité ou
l'artériosclérose ou etc il faut
commencer à manger mieux et mieux en
france c'est moins de viande moins de
l'est moins de sel moins de sucre moins
de graisse faut avoir le courage de le
dire alors ce n'est plus quoi plus de
céréales plus de légumineuses c'est à
dire plus de protéines végétales
pourquoi on abandonner le ralenti le
pois chiche et ses plus de fruits et de
légumes locaux de saison et plus de
diversité donc c'est possible donc ceci
ce qu'on peut furent ces choses et est
moindre et moins de gâchis et donc le
problème c'est la course de vitesse
est-ce que les gens qui sont une
propension maintenant se détruire la
santé parce qu'ils on mange trop vont
comprendre assez vite qu'il faut manger
moins et mieux pour laisser un peu plus
de parts par exemple aux africains qui
ont bien le droit d'appliquer la maxime
de bon henri iv la poule au pot tous les
dimanches moi je jouais pas pourquoi on
refuse aux africains de manger de la
viande une fois par semaine mais il est
urgentissime de dire nous va faut - se
bâfrer il faut faire de la qualité donc
c'est possible de nourrir tout le monde
si on gâche moins si on change de régime
alimentaire et si on se met à augmenter
la productivité dans les pays tropicaux
et notamment en afrique ou en théorie
c'est facile puisque la productivité est
actuellement très faible et les forces
de la nature sont fortes et c'est pas
par hasard qu'il ya plein de riches du
monde qui essaie d'acheter des terres en
afrique
alors on dit toujours les chinois mais
je vous rassure si les français il ya
plein de fonds d'investissement qui
achètent des terres partout mais
pourquoi ils font ça
attendez qu'elle est là mais des actions
qui font que a madagascar on tire deux
tonnes de riz à l'hectare alors qu'en
egypte 8 tonnes pourtant tout ça c'est
l'afrique donc koné coréen disent je
vais louer le tiers à bas prix ben le
tiers des terres du de madagascar pour
me faire du maïs pour les cochons des
coréens quelque part c'est très choquant
mais ce qui est encore plus choquant
c'est comme fasse que deux tonnes de riz
à l'hectare à madagascar pourquoi est-ce
qu'en algérie on produit moins de
nourriture que le jour de l'école la
décolonisation alors que depuis la
décolonisation de l'algérie on a triplé
la production agricole en france je ne
vois pas quelle est la malédiction qui
fait que l'algérie est un pays qu'ils
soient nuls en agriculture et d'ailleurs
quand il avait du pétrole qui valait
cher et c'est pas grave je vends du
pétrole pour acheter du blé est
maintenant que le pétrole est pas cher
ça commencé à ruer dans les brancards
des ambitions se faisait un peu de blé
j'ai ouï mais ont fait moins de blé en
algérie quant aux armes 1960 quand même
donc on peut forcément faire plus je
n'ai jamais remarqué tous les pays
condemi des puits de pétrole dont
général sourit crèvent la dalle soit ya
la guerche l'âme c'est une malédiction
c'est le football en salle voilà par
exemple année le congo asbl à la
république démocratique du congo futur
jeu quand on regarde une carte c'est
l'équivalent du brésil en fait ça
devrait être un très grand pays agricole
il ya des experts qui disent rien que le
ce pays pour entre 500 millions de
personnes ça devrait être un très grand
exportateur il devrait y avoir des
manifs contre les paysans congolais
comme il y en a contre les paysans
brésiliens chercher l'or ils ont des
mines ils ont des mines à face est une
espèce d'aberration de la nature un
pouvoir faible coup d'état guerre civile
40 en guerre et la guerre chasse marie
mal avec la fourchette 70 % des
congolais aux fins ils ont faim
puisqu'ils ont des mines
malheureusement c'est cynique et c'est
très triste à dire faut probablement
attendre la fermeture de la dernière
mine de diamants d'uranium et de cuir
pour qu'enfin le congo devienne ce qu'il
devrait être un grand pays agricole
alors il est du côté de la france il
faut qu'ils arrêtent de vendre des armes
et qu'on vante plutôt des agriculteurs
ou n'exporte des agriculteurs du savoir
faire et que on aide les paysans du
monde à se nourrir eux mêmes alors c'est
sûr que quand on passe son temps à
vendre des armes après non on a de la
bouteille et par auch rd1 ils s'en
servent à tarder les ont achetés pour
s'en servir vous épauleront prisme de
lecture on exporte la démocratie et les
écoles pour les petites filles c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le dire assez
d'accord bon à la question d'internet
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à notre
échelle où ledit besoin alors est ce
qu'on a besoin des politiques pour faire
cette transition est ce que la
population de ce montant évidemment cui
mais
quand même il faut pas s'affranchir de
sa responsabilité personnelle la
question qu'est ce que tu manges ce soir
c'est une question fondamentale qui
concerne l'avenir de l'humanité alors un
tout petit peu et ça concerne et donc
c'est normal de se demander qu'est ce
que tu manges ce soir je jouais en
particulier sur le réchauffement de la
planète il faut quand même dire que
l'agriculteur et surtout l'élevage c'est
le tiers des gaz à effet de serre émis
dans le monde voilà avec cette formule
choc et nous dit un gîte a rien qui
roulent en 4 4 et bien poli - la planète
qu'à cycliste carnivores parce que
finalement la viande quelque part ça
réchauffe plus la planète cole 4,4 alors
l'idéal c'est le cycliste vegan mais bon
tout le monde peut pas être à la fois
cyclistes et mégane mais tout le monde
peut se dire je mange de la viande
quatre fois par semaine ça suffit j'en
veux de la bonne je la marche
tranquillement je prends du plaisir mais
je suis pas obligé d'en manger 14 fois
par semaine alors quid de système amap
il a auch qui dit oui
alors il y en a joui que c'est génial
rien à dire maintenant
attendez un peu pas remplacer un système
par un autre dans la région parisienne à
10 millions de
de gens une amap grosso modo la ruche
qui dit oui c'est le même genre enfin
une amap 700 personnes qui achètent la
récolte sur pied de l'âne et d'un
agriculteur
il ya 10 millions à paris il faudrait
beaucoup d'un map un vrai sens mis la
map vous y croyez à cent mille
agriculteurs à moins de 50 kilomètres de
paris évidemment que non donc je veux
dire partout on peut faire deux circuits
courts c'est bien mais les circuits
courts ça peut pas être la norme dans un
monde où c'est d'abord des grandes
métropoles avec des millions d'habitants
je veux dire pour nourrir paris
l'ile-de-france ne suffit pas vous
n'êtes plus forte de normandie de
bretagne etc alors faut pas forcément
apporté du brésil est ce que vous
trouvez que les écologistes sont pincés
pragmatiques comme vous c'est à dire que
comme on dit
c'est difficile d'avoir une vision
globale des chiffres et donc tenez par
exemple l'autre jour là on a eu des
problèmes avec quelques quelques oeufs
au fipronil on a des insecticides touche
1 ont détruit
250 milles
le français moyen mais 250 milles c'est
énorme mais c'est quoi énorme bonjour ne
mange 40 millions par jour moi j'ai
visité une seule usine kasri 2 qui casse
un million de tous les jours donc c'est
trois heures il ya trois heures de la
production des usines qu'on a cassé on
mange 40 millions d'euros manche 15
milliards 2 les français par an et donc
c'est vrai que c'est difficile souvent
d'aborder à la fois sa consommation
personnelle et l'ensemble des grands
enjeux et il faut absolument produire
beaucoup de nourriture pour nourrir 7
milliard et demi d'habitants on arrive
vers la fin de notre interview je vais
vous passez vos bouquins vous allez nous
les présenter
oui mais bon voilà je veux pas faire du
commercial voilà j'ai écrit trois
bouquins sur ces thèmes-là alors le
premier qu'elle plus connus nourrir
l'humanité les grands peintres et
culture mondiale c'est ce dont on a
parlé comment on va faire pour nourrir
10 milliards d'habitants augmenté de 70%
le la production agricole mondiale mais
m mais avec une planète qui se réchauffe
c'est de plus en plus difficile et avec
des ressources qui ce qui diminue on
peut y arriver mais il faut il faut s'y
mettre alors ensuite j'ai fait un livre
sur l'alimentation
qu'est ce qu'on a dans la tête quand on
choisit ce qu'on mange tiens pourquoi on
mange des cochons nouveau et des
escargots mais pourquoi manges pas de
chien et je sais pas quoi moi des
sauterelles mais sauterelles c'est
beaucoup plus propre que l'escargot
s'étaient tous nos rapports je suis ce
que je mange nous sommes ce que nous
mangeons
derrière l'acte de manger il ya beaucoup
plus coder des calories ou d euros suis
beaucoup moins risqué en goodies huîtres
en france non cousine famine
mais on aurait pu manger des sauterelles
aux il ya beaucoup de centrales en
france bon voilà et puis me suis
intéressé à la faim dans le monde voit
la faim zéro en finir avec la faim dans
le monde on peut quand je dis la famine
est une création de l'homme
c'est à la fois une mauvaise et une
bonne nouvelle ce que l'homme a fait
l'homme peut le défaire alors tiens je
vais oser une comparaison
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine
il ya beaucoup moins de guerre sur terre
il n'y a jamais eu aussi peu de guerre
il faut aussi regarder les chiffres
2016 c'est l'année toute l'histoire de
l'humanité où il ya le moins de morts
violentes
c'est là
je dirais la conscience humaine elle
progresse à la révolution française on a
quand même guillotin guillotiné 17000
personnes sous les applaudissements de
la foule et fassent un téléthon mais
c'était ça maintenant comme des shs
rassemble trois personnes sur la plage
pour leur couper la tête c'est bien la
même chose et tout le monde ya créé du
coeur
mondial on est jeune c'est pas possible
au 20e siècle cinq pour cent des morts
sont violentes actuellement c'est 0,8
pour cent c'est beaucoup trop
mais si beaucoup moins il ya plus de
guerre en asie pratiquement enfin
l'héroïne gars encore voilà il ya plus
de gars en amérique latine y en a plus
en europe il ya des guerres au moyen
orient et dans le sahel bon et autrement
dit cette idée qui est née après la
deuxième guerre mondiale la guerre c'est
pas classe c'est pas une manière normale
de résoudre les problèmes
c'est malgré tout elle fait son chemin
et la guerre maintenant c'est un
scandale permanent
et en même temps il ya toujours autant
de gens qui ont faim il ya toujours
autant de gens qui meurent de faim est
donc finalement au 21ème siècle quand on
y réfléchit au mieux on meurt beaucoup
plus de faim que de guerre et moi qui
suis peut-être un incorrigible optimiste
je dis peut-être dans les 50 ans qui
viennent cette idée très simple un
enfant qui meurt de faim c'est quand
même pas normal va finir par faire son
chemin parce que si on veut qu'ils aient
plus d'enfants qui meurent de faim on
peut le faire et si on sait convaincus
que la guerre n'est pas une solution
normal pour résoudre les problèmes et
ben on peut aussi se dire quand même
terminons le job on a nourri 5 milliards
de gens de plus pourquoi on finit pas le
job avec les 800 derniers millions alors
ça à voir avec la guerre les réfugiés
etc mais ça a à voir avec la volonté
farouche te dire c'est pas normal que
sur terre il ya autant d'enfants qui
meurent de faim quand l'an 1900 est-ce
qu'on s'y met vraiment va vous poser la
dernière question qui
on va dire notre maroc laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
alors
comment dire
on vous inculque le fait qu'on a peur de
tout
je veux dire vous avez été élevé avec la
peur de l'amour puisque avait le sida
puis la peur de changer de boulot
puisque avait le chômage et moi je dis
arrêtons d'avoir peur
pressure to put allons-y non mais je
vais dire évidemment que je veux dire on
a le droit d'aimer on a le droit de
changer de boulot enfin en jeu des rangs
des super privilégié quand même donc on
peut et le vrai problème c'est par est
ce que je serai malade bon évidemment
faut prendre des précautions et est-ce
que je vais taux chômage c'est en quoi
le monde est un peu meilleures grâce à
moi or on a toujours tendance à dire
c'est les autres c'est le gouvernement
c'est le truc à calais syndicats les
patrons les trucs les machins mais
attendez on se regarde de temps en temps
dans la glace est ce que le monde est
meilleur grâce à moi qu'est ce que je
fais pour ce monde soit meilleur alors
meilleur comme vous voulez plus juste
plus beau plus sportive plus solidaire
plus ce que vous voulez et il ya quand
même des trucs qui reste le monde est
plus beau quand il est solidaire donc
c'est vachement bien de se débrouiller
pour s'enrichir en marchant sur les
autres mais ça tient pas c'est pas le
vrai bonheur vrai bonheur ces cas une
société où il ya plus de solidarité où
tout le monde avance ensemble et donc
osé construire un monde meilleur voilà
bruno parmentier merci merci
[Musique]
e